Speaker 1: All right, welcome everybody.
I think we're sort of at a point where it
makes sense to issue a reminder and go through
the data that there is still no actual evidence
that the COVID vaccines approved in the United
States have caused even one death, even a
single death.
And I had people yesterday sending me links
to the Joe Rogan Sanjay Gupta interview.
I had links to articles based on Veirs reporting,
and it just is a good time to refresh what
is actually known about the vaccines now.
This is not a segment about the Russian vaccine.
This is not a segment about the Chinese vaccine
and what they have or haven't done.
I just don't have data that I can look at
that I could say with any certitude that is
reliable data.
I'm not saying anything one way or the other
about those vaccines.
I just want to be clear that if you're going
to email me things about the Russian vaccine,
I am doing a segment here specifically about
the Pfizer vaccine.
The Moderna vaccine and the Johnson and Johnson
vaccines approved and available here in the
United States and on those there is no clear
evidence whatsoever that they have caused
any deaths in the United States.
Now this is different than have any vaccinated
people died of COVID last time.
Two months ago, I did a similar segment with
the data we had until then, and people wrote
to me and said, David, sir, actually, they
didn't say sir, they were less polite.
They said, David, you're lying.
There are plenty of vaccinated people that
have died.
That's different.
The question here is have the vaccines caused
deaths?
A couple of weeks ago, we had a very detailed
report from the CDC with the latest data on
adverse reactions to the vaccine.
Now, it's important to remember just because
someone submitted a report of a death caused
by the vaccine to the Veirs system virus doesn't
mean that someone actually died as a result
of the vaccine.
As the CDC reminds us, and I encourage you
to go through this article, we're linking
to this CDC page of adverse events described
on this page have been reported to the Veirs
system.
Veirs accepts reports of any adverse event
following vaccination that doesn't even mean
related to the vaccination, and we'll talk
about that in a second.
Also, remember that the FDA I'm sorry the
yes, the FDA requires that health care providers
report deaths that take place after COVID
vaccination, even if the health care provider
has no real reason to think that the death
is related to the vaccine.
It's just it happened after the vaccine.
Sometimes people die weeks after the vaccine
has nothing to do, even with COVID, never
mind the vaccine.
It's still supposed to be reported and then
evaluated.
And again, anybody can submit such a report,
as it says here.
Reports of adverse events to Veirs following
vaccination, including deaths, do not necessarily
mean that a vaccine caused a health problem.
So what has the CDC put out?
And this is their latest report.
It's a couple of weeks old now about vaccine
reactions and adverse events.
It's a matter of reading through these one
by one and understanding them first anaphylaxis
after COVID 19 vaccination.
It's rare it's occurred in two to five out
of every million vaccinated people in the
United States.
Severe allergic reactions, including anaphylaxis,
can occur after any vaccination if it occurs.
Vaccination providers can effectively and
immediately treat the reaction that's not
unique to the COVID vaccine, and it is extraordinarily
rare and treatable.
OK, thrombosis with thrombocytopenia syndrome
after the JNJ vaccine is rare.
As of October 6th, about eight days ago, more
than 15 million doses of the JNJ vaccine were
given.
There have been 47 reports of people who got
the vaccine and later developed teats thrombosis
with thrombocytopenia syndrome concentrated
among women under 50 years old.
OK, to date, two confirmed cases of TTS have
been reported with Moderna after 382 million
doses, so extraordinarily rare.
We then have, as has been the case with other
vaccines in the past GBS, Guillain-Barre syndrome
and people who got JNJ a very rare disorder.
15.
Million JNJ vaccines administered 228 preliminary
reports.
And those have to be looked at more closely.
Typically, men over 50.
So we talked about PTS very rare, concentrated
in women under 50 with the JNJ GBS very rare,
concentrated in men, over 50 with the JNJ.
We then heard of myocarditis and pericarditis
after COVID 19.
Very rare 16:40 reports in Veirs.
And again, remember anybody can submit that
and there's no question there's a bandwagon
effect.
If people start submitting, submitting, submitting,
you should look at what's been submitted to
Veirs.
16:40 Submitted among people under 30 most
cases reported, particularly in adolescent
males and young adults through follow up,
including medical records review the CDC and
FDA have confirmed about half 926 reports,
and the relationship to vaccination is still
being investigated and then reports of deaths.
This is a really important thing because Veirs
has received 86 reports of deaths, but even
linking them causally to the vaccine is not
something that has been done yet.
When you give hundreds of millions of people
a vaccine by sheer actuarial reality, the
fact that people die, people are going to
die in the days, weeks and months after receiving
a vaccine that's supposed to be reported to
Veirs, even if it's not believed to be because
of the vaccine.
And there is every reason to believe there
are lots of false reports.
But it is really important that we go by what
the CDC has assessed based on the data.
Now, what about blood clots?
That's another one that we've been hearing
a little bit about.
Researchers are still looking at whether there
is any connection between JNJ and a rare type
of blood clot.
Very, very few cases still being investigated.
And once we have something more definitive
on that, we will talk about it.
So when you hear the talking point is basically
look at all of the deaths that have been reported.
People talk about tens of thousands, hundreds
of thousands of deaths due to the vaccine.
The actual number of deaths reported to the
system is 80 600, and there has been no confirmation
that it is because of the vaccine.
They are deaths that took place after individuals
were vaccinated.
That's the data.
I have no interest in hiding or exaggerating
or downplaying anything that is the data as
we know it right now.
And with time, we will continue to get updated
reports.